Many of you,
I presume have seen breaking bad and
that's a really good example of the of
the incorporation at least in part or
maybe the possession by the shadow from
the Union perspective,
right?
Because you have this ordinary high
school teacher who really thinks that
he's an ax and his family as well.
You know,
like your typical persona,
roughly speaking,
he's just a normal guy,
but part of the reason that he's a
normal guy is because he actually hasn't
been put in abnormal circumstances and
then all of a sudden he is and he has a
genuine moral conundrum.
Right?
He's going to die of lung cancer and
his.
He has a son who's got a lot of health
problems and he's terrified that he's
going to leave his wife and his child
behind with nothing and then of course
as the story and so he decides to do
something that temporarily that he
regards as what they would normally
regard as reprehensible and of course
you just gets tangled up in that.
But then as the story unfolds,
you see that there's.
It's more complicated because it's not
that he was just innocent.
Good guy and he decided to turn bad.
He's also very resentful and angry and
it's partly because he's a bit of a
pushover at the beginning or maybe more
than a bit of a pushover and also that
he didn't really fulfill his own
potential and that,
you know,
he,
he had friends who walked down the
entrepreneurial path and maybe they
weren't quite fair to him,
but whatever,
he ends up not very successful as a high
school teacher.
So he's really angry about that.
And so there's more motivation for him
opening up the door to the terrible
elements of his personality than just
the fact that he's got good motivations
to do so and that,
that unfolds,
you know,
and so he would see that warps and
twists and is resentful.
Character increasingly manifest
themselves as he walks down this road to
really total brutality.
And it,
it's,
it's quite good.
Um,
there's a book called ordinary men
that's a lot like that.
I don't think I've mentioned that to you
before,
but ordinary men is a book about.
It's the best book of it's type.
Maybe it's the only book of its type.
It's possible,
but it's plotted,
much like breaking bad in some sense.
It's a story about these German
policemen in early stages of World War
II and they were guys who were old
enough to be raised in Germany really
before the hitlarian propaganda came out
in full force,
you know,
if you were a teenager,
say in the 1930,
so you were going to be pulled right
into the propaganda machine and maybe
you were part of the Hitler youth and
like you were raised in that,
you know,
but if you were older than you were
raised before that and you're not as
amenable to propaganda once you're older
than a boat.
While I would say about 22 or something
like that.
It's,
it's pretty young actually.
If you're gonna make a soldier,
you have to get a soldier young because
once people are in their early twenties,
say they're kind of.
They already have their personality
developed.
Anyways.
These policemen were sent into Poland
after the Germans marched through and
uh,
you know,
it was war time and there is this
hypothesis in Germany that the Jews in
particular,
we're operating as a fifth column and
undermining the German war effort
because of course the Germans blame the
Jews and a variety of other people for
actually setting up the conditions that
made the war necessary.
And so when the police were sent into
Poland,
they were also required to make peace
roughly speaking.
And so they started up by.
They started out by rounding up all the
Jewish men between 18 and 65 and
gathering them in,
in stadiums and then shipping them off
on the trains.
But that isn't where they ended.
They ended in,
in very,
very dark place.
I mean,
these guys were going out in the field
with naked pregnant women and shooting
them in the back of the head by the end
of their training.
And what's really interesting about that
is that is that their commander told
them that they could go home at any
time.
So this is,
this is not one of those examples of
people following orders and the reason
they didn't,
roughly speaking,
there's many reasons,
but one of the reasons they didn't is
because they didn't think it was
comradely,
so to speak,
to leave there,
the guys they were working with to do
all the dirty work and run off,
you know.
And that's really,
that's really an interesting fact,
you know,
because you're in different
circumstances,
you wouldn't think about that as
reprehensible,
right?
You'd think,
well that's part of teamwork and under
rough circumstances and that's at least
in part how they viewed it.
And they were also made physically ill
multiple times physically and
psychologically ill by the things that
they had to do,
but they kept doing them anyways.
So it's one step at a time.
And that's the thing is that you end up
in very bad places one step at a time.
So you gotta watch those steps.